les festivités qui se sont amorcées dès
la fin du match du super bowl à miami et
se sont poursuivis avec le défilé à
kansas city ont atteint un autre niveau
pour laurent du vernis tardif rentrer à
montréal samedi soir les premiers
moments où il a retrouvé sa famille sur
le terrain à miami resteront marqués à
jamais quel bon moment j'avais jamais vu
ma mère pleurait de joie comme ça puis
mon père était élu de voir florence
aussi pitié c'est quand même un instant
que tu te rends compte de tous ces
efforts là encore payer pour ce moment
le de kenza cité de miami dans sa
préparation pour le super bowl le rang
du vernis tardif a bien senti l'appui
des québécois et s'en est servi comme
motivation quand une blessure au mollet
il est compliqué son travail dimanche
dernier qui on le fait pour la gagne de
la gang d'amis euros pour les parents
pour le monde au québec on dirait que
chaque jour j'essaie de me trouver une
motivation supplémentaire pour le faire
tout en restant positif
les célébrations et les hommages se
multiplieront au cours des prochaines
semaines
il procédera notamment à la mise au jeu
protocolaire du match des canadiens
lundi soir et si les chiffres sont
invités à la maison blanche
il ira pour son équipe c'est un voyage
d'equipe ça fait partie de toute cette
célébration un carton le super bowl puis
je pense que ça n'a rien à voir avec
nous nos opinions personnelles
en ce qui a trait à la politique ça sera
aussi probablement assez perçu
négativement d'être le seul canadien ne
pas aller à la maison blanche
mais je pense que je vu cette expérience
pour la suite ce sera le retour à la
réalité
pas de médecine pour lui cet hiver
puisqu'il n'amorcera sa résidence
qu'après sa carrière de football en
attendant il tentera d'inspirer les
jeunes à suivre ses traces
peu importe quel est leur passion si un
jeune envie de faire du théâtre puis de
pousser sa carrière plus haut possible
tout en faisant un doctorat en génie
biomédical ou peu importe qu'ils fassent
jean saint-onge radio canada
on rire